hello and welcome to the new reviewer
source for everything anime and manga
and today we're here to talk about
hunters hunting things and one hunter in
particular his name is kite and he is
the subject of a fair bit of confusion
in good old hunter hunter because i've
noticed that a lot of people come away
from either the anime or even the manga
and they aren't exactly sure what
happened to kite and to be fair kite's
story is tied into two fairly complex
arcs being the chimera antarc and the
german election one of which aims to
explore the subtleties of existence
itself whilst the other explores well
not that i mean i guess it kind of does
with alukar and everything but the
chairman election is more or less a mess
of administration which is very relevant
because that mess is where kite's
conclusion takes place so this video is
going to serve to untangle all of that
detail of not only what happened to kite
but also how it happened and what is
likely to happen with him in the future
and it's all going to begin with a quick
round of clown kite a very simple mini
game the rules of which are as follows
here we have three kites dressed in
clown outfits for some reason doesn't
matter what the reason is don't ask
questions but two of these clown bros
are nen clones and it is going to be
your job to guess which one is the real
kite now should you guess incorrectly
then your punishment will be to
subscribe to the new old review which
will result in consistent injections of
hunter-based culture administered
directly into your youtube feed and if
you are correct then kite will turn you
into a clown hooray so which kite will
it be a b or the other one make your
choice now and we shall reveal the
answer in three two one and bam it was
kite b so if you guessed incorrectly
then you know thing to do and please do
say hi in the comments below if you are
new to our association welcome let's go
ahead and fly this kite though as the
very first character introduced not only
in the chimera antarctic but also hunter
hunter itself with the manga kite is
well here's a bit of a big deal he has
this mentor minty relationship with gone
which leads to an unfortunate tragedy
during the conflict with neferpito fun
little thing here though that for some
reason almost never gets brought up
because according to moral knuckle and
off kite actually touched pitozen on
purpose to figure out how powerful they
were this isn't clear during the actual
event and it just looks like pito sensed
kite out of nowhere but really what kite
did is essentially the equivalent of
poking a beehive just to find out how
many bees are inside and as it turns out
there were a lot of bees like a critical
mass of bees really which is important
because gone's entire character arc for
this what quarter of the series is about
blaming himself for kite's death because
kite had to protect him however the
reality of the situation is that kite
f'ed up he effed up pretty bad and he
paid for his own mistake by saving gone
and killer which does lead to our first
big mystery the last we see of a living
kite is him having activated crazy slots
and having it land on number three the
mace this is a weapon that kite refers
to as a quote good number as opposed to
the other two we saw but then the very
next thing we see is his severed head
lying in pito's lap so clearly the
number wasn't quite good enough but
maybe it was we'll get back to that now
this is unknown to us at the time but
the next we see of kite is his rebirth
into the world as merowim's twin this
minuscule baby thing is then taken by
colt who names herrena in honor of his
sister however small baby then grows up
extraordinarily quickly and just with
many of the ants she recalls her past
human life and chooses to adopt the
former name of kite now there's a lot of
questions here questions such as how how
is a very good one y is also a fantastic
choice though for example how did kite
soul make its way into a chimera ant
without going through the fadrogenesis
process and why does this and only this
chimera ant appear to be fully human
that's probably the most unusual thing
of all because every other ant was mixed
with the dna of other creatures as it is
i'm not personally 100 sure that kite is
a chimera ant which is a weird thing to
say because kite's current body was born
directly from an ant but it's weird it's
just weird and let's explore why firstly
it should be noted that there's no
guaranteed explanation for how this
phenomena occurred i'd like to emphasize
that kite was not ingested by the ant
queen he died and his body was then left
with pitot to play with like some sort
of a toy thing so at no stage did any
physical part of kite enter the chimera
ant process so what we're left with is
purely jing's hypothesis because in
chapter 335 he says the following i
taught kite everything he knows about
nen his crazy slot has a number that
only comes up when he really doesn't
want to die if he's alive that's
probably why so it's implied that slot
number three the mace could have had the
effect of reincarnating kite's soul in
the event of death but that is only half
the story because we also need to
address the new body as two chapters
later in 337 we spent quite a bit of
time focusing on koala who as an
australian i have to hold as my favorite
chimera aunt the only better outcome
would have been to have a kangaroo ant
but sadly that did not eventuate in any
case mr kawawa recognizes kait's body as
having previously belonged to a young
girl that he murdered and koala's
reasoning for this was that he wanted to
save the girl from the fate that he had
endured of becoming an ad so he killed
her before the girl's soul could become
part of the ant reincarnation cycle
however her body was still consumed so
it appears that our bodyless soul of
kite found the soulless body of this
here random girl with that said there
are also plenty of other humans who died
before being fed to the queen so it was
less of a destined match-up than maybe
the story would proclaim it was just a
very suitable vessel that popped up in
the exact time in which kitesaur was
making its way back into the world and
just on the the soul stuff for a second
hunter hunter does very casually confirm
the existence of a soul there's a
question during the chimera ant talk
over whether ants possess the souls of
consumed humans or if they've just
inherited genetic memories in a process
that i'll describe as
somehow but it kind of doesn't matter
because the kite situation does clear
this up as it's not possible for an ant
to have inherited any genetic
information from kite it is however a
pretty insane use of nen and i would
propose that this is actually an
invocation of post mortem then we've
seen this used on several occasions and
individual setting conditions designed
to endure after their death and another
great example would be pito actually who
ordered their terps quarter heart suit
to dance beyond its limits thus
resulting in a terrifying single-minded
nan corpse being brought into existence
following pito's death so i imagine that
the only reason that kite was able to
achieve something as shockingly powerful
as reincarnation is due to the
post-mortem conditions the crazy slot's
mace in and of itself is almost
certainly a completely useless weapon to
wield its battle potential would have to
be minimal to form part of the
restrictions to invoke such a powerful
effect but the question then becomes was
it kite's ability that was able to
provide him with this seemingly almost
fully human form or was it just a freak
coincidence of biology why was kite the
only chimera ant born with seemingly no
properties of ant at least no physically
distinguishing qualities of ant and it
really could go either way this could
just be a sliver of human dna that
somehow avoided meshing and blending too
much with every other consumed creature
or it could be that kite's post mortem
then selected that dna and then kept it
free of all sorts of crazy and
alterations and i should also say that
it's not clear what kite believes
actually happened to him or i suppose
now herself koala tells a very
convincing story but in the end it's
difficult to tell if kite's buying into
it or not kite more or less just
emotionally conscripts koala into
becoming something of a slave for the
remainder of his life it's actually kind
of twisted when you think about it
because even if it is true that kite
inherited this specific girl's body he
is not that girl as an individual he
really has no right to demand the koala
atone via serving him specifically but
look it's it's a big grey area koala is
obviously not the most morally sound of
individuals due to his history as a
killer before even turning into a killer
hand although it does fit with kite's
personality as we know him for example
in the past kite profusely chastised
god's actions because his ignorance led
to him needing to kill a fox bear when
he was young and gone went on to atone
for that action by adopting and raising
the fox bear cub so perhaps kite's
attitude towards koala is just a more
extreme example of writing the damage
caused to nature what's also interesting
is that jing reinforces that this entire
situation is it's more or less kite's
fault when speaking to gon jin quite
blatantly states that kite took him
along because he thought it would be an
easy mission and he critically
underestimated the severity of what was
happening in fact jing's exact quote is
he got cocky it was his fault and you
know i give jing a lot of crap for being
a bad father but this was probably the
best thing he could have said to gone at
this particular point the kid who was
saddled with this immense guilt for a
death that really he had no part in
causing with that said it's hard to
argue that things have turned out too
terribly for kite as a result of this
reincarnation he actually re-enters
hunter hunter with a bit of a double
power-up if he is part chimera ants then
that brings with it a lot of innate
physical advantages as well as raw aura
benefits the ants were all unnaturally
gifted when it came to aura quantity and
given that kite was born alongside the
most gifted of all of the ants the ant
king marouane then that may very well
make kite one of the most powerful nen
users in the series to date i mean no
obviously meruem took the bulk of that
aura advantage but i'd find it very
difficult to believe that kite didn't
inherit anything at all via this process
but the other avenue we definitely need
to look at is from the post-mortem then
angle because yes it's great to invoke
aura to avoid death or at least use
death to your advantage but the other
key factor about this is that surviving
a post mortem then experience results in
a ridiculous power-up of all facets of
nenus which is pretty wild because kite
was already one of the more outrageously
powerful hunters in the series the thing
that really held him back as we've
explored was simply experience and
personal judgment that's the brutality
of hunter hunter if you make one mistake
no matter who you are you're done but
kite today despite being far physically
younger is much more mentally mature and
that maturity is a very very good
combination with the double whammy then
multiplier although a big question i
have is whether or not nen abilities
transcend this reincarnation process
like can kites still invoke crazy slots
or was part of the reincarnation
condition the abandonment and
destruction of crazy slots i suppose it
may not necessarily matter either way
because kite now has the sheer
quantities of aura to casually craft a
new op none ability if needed i just
think it would be interesting to see an
amped up version of crazy slots
furthermore it would also be intriguing
to see if kite's net affinity has
changed previously he was a conjurer but
who knows what happens to that idea with
reincarnation it's completely unexplored
you know is a net affinity attached to
the soul of an individual is it more
personality based as hisoka would
propose or is it something that is
assigned via raw genetics at birth
there's a lot of interesting potential
to be explored with kite-specific
situation and there's even a decent
possibility that he's graduated and
morphed into a specialist which would in
effect kind of turn kite into what pito
was a specialist bottomless pit of ore
who can craft any ability that takes
their fancy except in the hands of kite
this would be put to far far better use
due to his exceptionally calculated
knowledge of men but also bear in mind
that the next time we see kite he will
have likely matured into a full on
physical adult as well so we've got some
very rapid evolution happening which i
suppose is actually the best possible
argument to say that kite does possess
chimera and dna this growth is obviously
far far too quick for a standard human
which in turn means that kite's
technical classification is now that of
a magical beast which is what the hunter
association essentially labels any
sentient life that is not 100 human
whatever the case kite is a character
who really should not be forgotten his
existence is incredibly downplayed and
treated as a sort of quick epilogue
however the implications of kite having
survived this encounter and the
specifics of how that occurred may very
well have created one of the most
powerful nen users that we've seen to
date or perhaps even ever will see in
hunter hunter meanwhile here is one of
the most powerful hunter hunter youtube
based videos that we will ever see and i
want you to click it because there's
always more to learn explore and
experience with this wonderful series so
i look forward to seeing you there